It is celebrated because the Magi was
when they came to visit the baby Jesus
to bring him the offerings in time.
We have to look for the products for
which the bagels are attached. We all have
to look for it in time to be able to
store and be ready for Three
Kings Day approximately like  about 100 120
bagels more or less this year is a
little different because
families don't get together as before when
20 30 people used to get together so right now
the bagels do sell but smaller
sizes for smaller families not
as much as other years  Three Wise Men
for those of us who
grew up in Mexico are more important
than Santa Claus than here in the
US for us in
Mexico the three wise men
descended where children receive their
gifts
more than they do today